storm Dennis may have passed but many
waking up this morning face the
challenge of piecing our lives back
together for those living on the banks
of the River Severn there is however the
worry of further damage warnings have
been in place across the length of the
river with residents being told to move
to a place of safety only a few miles
west of the Severn is the river teaming
10 Barrie due to the sheer amount of
water the Environment Agency has told
those living around the team that their
lives are at risk
but communities who have been affected
are frustrated with the government this
from the Yorkshire Post we're drowning
Prime Minister act now in September the
Environment Secretary promised more than
2.6 billion hangs for flood defense
projects but criticism even comes from
Boris Johnson's own party the MP for
Shipley in West Yorkshire Philip Davies
has said that precious little has been
spent on protecting his constituents
since flooding in 2015 many people have
been trapped in their own homes and
businesses trying to escape the water
including this man we were inside about
four o'clock trying to fight the flood
get the water out I'd no luck at all and
unfortunately it got to the point we had
to just say just go upstairs and find
sleep
in South Wales one man has died after
falling into the river TOWIE these
people in Nanta guru had to grab what
they could to escape the water in Creek
howl a helicopter was used to help those
cut off after the river asked burst its
banks dozens have had to be rescued here
meanwhile the cleanup has begun in Ponte
prief where roads became rivers perhaps
in the morning the water started
crashing over the top of the wall and
didn't stop
it was just kept going and going and
going and we saw an actual car with this
lights on going down the river and the
worst of it is we've got insurance
because the premiums so high after the
last floods despite attempts from the
families and business owners to get back
to work this morning police are still
warning the public to be careful and
we're working very closely with their
colleagues in the natural resources
Wales and Met Office to ensure that we
keep ourselves Billy up to speed with
developments with what the weatherman
looked like tonight tomorrow and for the
rest of the week for now these
communities are getting on with
rebuilding their lives but many will be
asking why the scenario keeps repeating
itself and if they'll ever be able to
live in complete safety in their homes
Jenny Longden Sky News